اذا رغم الهدنه المعلنه تتواصل الاشتباكات
المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع وسط سماع لدوي انفجارات في ام
درمان مع تحليق للطائرات الحربيه واطلاق
نار في محيط القصر الرئاسي الانباء
متضاربه ايضا حول عمليات الطرفين العسكريه
حيث شهد وسط العاصمه الخرطوم ومحيط
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه شهد
اشتباكات عنيفه واعلن الطرفان السيطره على
وسط الخرطوم والقياده العامه فمن جهتها
قالت القوات البريه للجيش السوداني انها
تسيطر على محيط القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه في الخرطوم اما قوات الدعم السريع
فنشرت صورا لما قالت انه انتشار لعناصرها
في شوارع وسط الخرطوم فيما نفى الجيش ذلك
كما نشرت الدعم السريع صورا للاستيلاء على
مدرعات عسكريه في شارع مدني بالخرطوم
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
يسيطرون على كل المواقع الاستراتيجيه
الحيويه على مستوى الدوله السودانيه
معروفين بالقتال والشراسه
عن حقنا وندافع عن الشعب السوداني ونحن
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الوضع الانساني في السودان يسوء يوما بعد
اخر حيث اظهرت صور بثها نشطون سودانيون
انتشارا للجثث في شوارع العاصمه وتحديدا
في المنطقه الصناعيه في الخرطوم بحري
عساكر
عسكري
ات مغلفه
وتعليقا على ذلك قال مصطفى ادم احمد مديره
منظمه الزرقاء للتنميه قال ان عمليه جمع
الجثه المتناثره في شوارع الخرطوم باتت
تشكل عمليه معقده لاسيما المساحه الواسعه
التي تنتشر فيها ومشكله تحلل هذه الجثث ما
يشكل خطرا على الوضع الصحي والبيئي في
المدينه
وفي هذا السياق اكدت رئيسه اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر ميريانا سبولياريتش ان تعذر
وصول المساعدات الى السودان يعود بالاساس
الى عدم تقديم طرفي النزاع ضمانات امنيه
ودعت رئيسه اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
دعت الاطراف المعنيه الى تمكين فرقها من
ايصال المساعدات من دون عراقيل واضافت
المسؤوله ان اولويات اللجنه هي تقديم
المساعدات الطبيه للمستشفيات في السودان
معربه عن استعداد المنظمه لايصال مزيد من
الامدادات فور توقف الاقتتال
كما اعلن الهلال الاحمر السوداني عن تعرض
مخازن الجمعيه التابعه له في الخرطوم بحري
للسطو بواسطه افراد مسلحين وقال الهلال
الاحمر ايضا ان مسلحين مجهولين نهبوا
ثمانيه سيارات ذات دفع رباعي وشاحنه تتبع
للجمعيه لافتا الى ان اطراف النزاع ستسعى
لمساعدته في استعاده سيارات الجمعيه
المسروقه وحذر الهلال الاحمر من ان سوء
استخدام السيارات المسروقه التابعه له
ستؤدي الى عواقب وخيمه لاسيما تلك التي
تحمل شعار الهلال الاحمر
بدوره قال سكرتير نقابه الاطباء السودانيه
عطيه عبد الله عطيه قال ان اقل من عشره
مستشفيات تعمل في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم حيث باتت هي الاخرى مهدده
بالانهيار وسط استمرار الاشتباكات بين
طرفي النزاع
المستشفيات يمكن التي يعني تعمل الان هي
اقل من عشره مستشفيات تعمل بصوره جيده
واغلبها هو عرضه للتوقف في اي لحظه نقص
الامداد نقص الكوادر
المتحدث باسم منظمه الصحه العالميه حذر من
تدهور الوضع في المستشفيات السودانيه مع
تصاعد مستويات العنف والفوضى وشكل الصراع
المسلح بين المكونين العسكريين تحديا
كبيرا على القطاع في ظل ارتفاع اعداد
القتلى والجرحى ونقص الموارد الطبيه
اللازمه
لا هدنه تصمد ولا عيد يشفع فاللغه الخصوم
تحتد اكثر ويكثر الرصاص يسمع صدى هنا يسقط
مدنيون ويتداعى قطع باكمله قتلى وجرحى
بالعشرات اكثر من 600 قتيل ومئات الجرح
بحسب وزاره الصحه السودانيه اعداد تضغط
على قطاع طبي على وشك الانهيار
خروج متواليه لعدد من المستشفيات خارج
الخدمه وايضا هنالك عدد من المستشفيات
الاخرى ايضا هي على حافه الاغلاق وزاره
الصحه السودانيه قالت
مستشفيات تعمل بكامل طاقتها في الخرطوم
وبينت ان عشره مستشفيات حكوميه خرجت عن
الخدمه في العاصمه نقابه الاطباء قالت ان
14 مستشفى تعرضت للقصف في البلاد بينما
يعملون نحو 23 مستشفى بشكل جزئي لكنها
مهدده بالاغلاق
الطبيه
[موسيقى]
الكوارث الطبيه
وفي ظل ظروف صعبه تعمل منظمات دوليه
واماميه لدعم القطاع الطبي المنهك لكن
القتال يعقد اي مسعا لذلك منظمه اطباء بلا
حدود قالت ان فريقها الطبي لم يتمكن من
ادخال امدادات طبيه اضافيه الى السودان
المنظمه اشارت الى ان الامدادات في مستشفى
الفاشر مثلا تكفي لثلاثه اسابيع فقط
من مدينه مروي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي اهلا بك معنا نزار اذا هذه
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم مستمره ولكن الوضع
في مرويه يستمر بالهدوء مل انباء الوارده
لديك حول مجريات المعارك في المناطق
الاخرى مثل الخرطوم وغيرها من المناطق
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد ان اعلن الجيش السوداني القوات
المسلحه
السيطره والاحكام على كل
بالمطار وبالقاعده
بالمناطق الجنوبيه
نحو خريطه الاحداث المتلاحقه في الخرطوم
لحكم الرفض والمتابعه ساعه بعد ساعه لما
يدوم
كما تشاهدون الان حاله
الاشتباكات المتقطعه واصوات الرصاص في عدد
من مناطق الخرطوم هذا مؤكد عليه حتى
اللحظه التي نتحدث فيها
يوم الامس بعد ان وردت المعلومات عن تحرك
قوات تابعه للدعم السريع في الطريق القومي
الذي يرضي بين العاصمه الخرطوم وولايه
تواصلنا صباح هذا اليوم مع عدد من
المواطنين والسكان
وعديده الصحفيين في مدينه واد مدني حاضره
ولايه الجزيره قالوا بان الامور مستقره
وان هذه القوات لم تصل الى مدينه واد مدني
كانت يوم الامس حاله من الخوف والقلق من
ان تمتد نيران الصراع المسلح من الخرطوم
الى ولايه الجزيره وسط السودان لكن العديد
المواطنين الذين تحدثنا معهم
قالوا بان الامور هادئه الامور مستقره
حاله الخوف انجلت تماما مساء الامس عندما
تم التعامل كما قالوا مع هذه القوات
العسكريه من قبل الجيش في دارفور ايضا
حاله الهدوء النسبي تسيطر
على المقاطعه وقبل ان نتحدث عن الوضع في
دارفور لنستمع قليلا الى صوت الاشتراكات
المستمر في العالم
اذا اصوات الاشتباكات وتبادل طلق النار
تتعالى في العاصمه الخرطوم اثر استمرار
هذه الاشتباكات رغم الهدنه نزار كنت تتحدث
معي عن الوضع في دار فورد تفضل
ما الوضع في دارفور كثيرون اشادوا بالخطوه
التي تقدمت بها السلطات في ولايه شمال
دارفور في مدينه الفاشر الاحتكام لصوت
العقل عدم الانجرار وراء العنف المسلح
الامور تنظيف نحو خط سلمي يبدو ان الحكومه
نجحت بعد ان ارتفعت حصيله الاشتباكات التي
حدثت خلال ثلاثه ايام الماضيه
وعشرات الاصابات الان الفاشل يمكن ان نقول
بانها هادئه نسبيا نياله الجيش يؤكد بانه
يحكم القبض على المقر الرئيسه والحكوميه
انتشار للفرقه السادس عشر مشاه في نياله
الاوضاع تمضي نحو الهدوء
اذا ما انتقل الدار الى كردفان من دارفور
الى الى كردفان
الجيش فيها الابيض صحيح
انا من الفوضى المدينه خلال الايام
الماضيه ولكن بعد ان تدخل الجيش ايضا عدسه
الامور الى نصابها لكن حاله عدم الاستقرار
والتوتر في النفوس مع زالت جاسمه خاصه وان
حصيله الموتى كانت في ارتفاع وعضد اللصاق
واحراق لمحال تجاريه داخل سوق مدينه
الاوبيض ورغبه الكثيرين من سكان مدينه
الابيض في مغادره المدينه
خلقه واقع افضل مما عايشوه خلال الساعات
الماضيه والايام الماضيه لكن الان حاله
الهدوء تسود بقيه مناطق ايضا تعيش حاله من
الترقب حاله من الهدوء والهدوء النسبي
لانهم يتابعون ويراقبون وينظرون الى
مسارات الامر العسكري والامني في الخرطوم
التي
يتخوف كثيرون من ان تشهد مزيد من حرب
المدن وحرب المدن تعني في المصطلحات
العسكريه بانها في حكم العمليات الخاصه
والعمليات الخاصه
عبر الشوارع وعبر الاحياء وعبر الطرقات
عبر الاليات وعبر الاسلحه وهذا ايضا مما
يتخوف منه المواطنون ونحن شاهد ونتابع
القذائف التي تسقط في ام درمان
تضيف مزيد من القتلى الى السجل واللائحه
القتل الذين سقطوا ضحايا وابرياء نتيجه
هذه الاشتباكات المسلحه وبالتاكيد تضيف
الى عدد الجثث المقاه على الشوارع والتي
يعني تحذر الجهات من ربما ان تخلق ازمه
صحيه كارثيه في الزداء في السودان طيب
نزار تفضل
نعم كنت اريد ان اشير الى هذه النقطه
واشير ايضا الى ما قاله طبيب الاحمر عندما
اخرج بيانا وتحدث فيه بصوره واضحه
بانه يواجه صعوبه وهنالك تعذر في ايصال
المساعدات لان الاطراف لم تمنح الضمانات
الضروريه لهم كجهات مسؤوله من هذا الامر
هنالك ايضا مناشده من هذا الصليب الاحمر
بامكانيه الوصول الفوري وهو يتحدث بانه
لابد ان تكون الامور مهياه ويجب ان تبتعد
كل العراقيل لاغراض الانسانيه لمد يد
العون للمدنيين السودانيين ايضا الصليب
الاحمر هو يبا سلسله الجهات التي قالت
بانها في حاجه الى ان تدخل
اشار فيما اشار الى ان الاولويه الملحه
الان تتمثل في تقديم المساعدات هي
للمستشفيات العمل على اصلاح البنيه
التحتيه للمياه والطاقه وغيرها لكن تبقى
مساله الجثث ومساله تبدي الوضع الصحي
والبيئي الذي سيتفاقم يوما بعد يوم اذا لم
تتدخل الجهات المعنيه والجهات الماليه اذ
ارادت ان تتدخل فلا بد من مسارات امنه
وهذه المسارات الامنه حتى في ظل هذه
الهدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام يبدو انها غير
متاحه وهذا ما يعقد الله على ما هو عليه
من تعقيدات من الشوائب تحيط بالمشهد
الامني والعسكري في السودان ورغم هذه
الهدنه التي يتم خرقها باستمرار الا ان
مستشار حميتي يقول للعربيه في هذا العجل
بان الحرب مفروضه علينا لكننا نظل ملتزمين
بالهدنه اذا كانوا هم ملتزمون بالهدنه
نزار اذا من الذي يخرق الهدنه
المواطن والمدنيين في السودان لا يتحطون
عن من يخرق الهدنه ومن يطلق الرصاص الاولى
هم يتحدثون عن من يكتوي بهذه الحرب لافاده
السودانيين في هذه التوقيتات الحرجه هم
غير معنيين بحتميه هذا الصراع
باستمراريه هذا الصراع بقدر ما يتحدثون من
السودانيين من ياضح للجرحى من
النساء في حاله الولاده التي يوجد هنا
يجابهنها في عدد من البيوت ولا يستطيعن ان
يتحركن صوب المستشفيات هذا هو السؤال
المطروح
الملح
يجب مواطنا سوداني نفسه امام فوهه البنادق
ويجد نفسه في مواجهه للقذائف ولازيد
الطائرات بغض النظر عن من المستفيد ومن
هذا الحرب الاوضاع ملتبكه في السودان
الامور معقده كل مصدر بيان والاخرى تصدر
اخر لكن الواقع والمؤكد بان هنالك حاله من
الاستياء هنالك حاله من التذمر هنالك حاله
من الشجب والادانه من قبل المواطنين وهم
يرون بانهم الوقود لهذه الحرب وهم الضحايا
الحقيقين لحرب ما زالت مستمره لاكثر من
ثمانيه ايام وفي ظل كل ذلك ايضا الدمار
يستمر للمدنيين ومنازلهم وايضا المناطق
المحيطه بهم حيث اقبل ثاني ايام عيد الفطر
والحرب مستمره بين الجيش والدعم السريع
ولا يزال السودانيون
يتعثرون بين مخلفات الدمار الذي طال
بيوتهم نتيجه القصف المتبادل بين الجانبين
لا عيد في استقبال زائر ولا حديثا مستعجلا
عند الوداع قست الجدران على صاحبها في
قلبها سواد دمار لا غير يتعرف هذا الرجل
على منزل تغيرت ملامحه انقلب راسا على عقب
والارض لا تسعه وان مدت له يد العون
حديث الرصاص في صباحات العيد احتفظ المكان
بالادله قذيفه ورصاصات طائشه يخمن محمود
الطيب تفاصيل ما حل بمنزله وسط العديد في
العاصمه الخرطوم
في الحديد فوق الزجاج
[موسيقى]
من الحديد ضربت هنا وبعد زي المسافه
النزح اهل الدار
تركوا ورائهم حادثه بيت مدمر نجحوا الى
ولايات سودانيه مجاوره بعيدا عن ساحه
الصراع بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
مئات السودانيين نجحوا الى ولايات مجاوره
للخرطوم شمالا وجنوبا مناطق وان كانت
بعيده نسبيا عن الاشتباكات الا ان خارطه
المعارك تنذر بامتداد الصراع محتدم الى
اطراف الخرطوم وابعد غيداء السالم العربيه
العربيه مشاهدينا هي اول وسيله اعلاميه
تتمكن من تصوير قاعده الدعم السريع في
منطقه جبل سركاب شمال ام درمان وكانت قوات
الجيش السوداني قد سيطرت على القاعده قبل
ايام
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
قاعده سركاب كانت معسكر خاصا بجهاز الامن
والمخابرات قبل اندلاع ثوره ديسمبر
القاعده تقع بالجوار من منطقه كرر
العسكريه
تجاور القاعده بعض فروع القوات المسلحه
كالقوات الخاصه والمحموله جوا في اطار
المنطقه العسكريه
معسكر سركاب تحول لقاعده عملياتيه توفر
الامداد والتعيينات تعد بحسب الخبراء
العسكريين موقعا استراتيجيا
تتعالج صيحات الدوليه لوقف الحرب الدائره
في السودان وفي هذا السياق حضرت مجموعه
الازمات الدوليه من حرب اهليه مدمره وذلك
اذا استمرت الاشتباكات بين طرفي الحرب
المنظمات الدوليه نصحت الجهات السودانيه
الفاعله والجهات الخارجيه ممن تربطها
علاقات مع عبد الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدان
والمعروف بحميتي ان تطالبهما بوقف القتال
فورا واضافت ان القتال خلف مئات القتلى
وحاصر الالاف متوقعه ان يكون عدد الوفيات
اكبر بكثير كما رجحت ان ينتصر للجيش على
الدعم السريع في الخرطوم وقالت في حال
استطاع الجيش تامين العاصمه وانسحب حميدتي
الى دارفور فمن الممكن ان تتبعها حرب
اهليه وتوقعت مجموعه الازمات الدوليه ان
ما يحدث ستكون له تبعات اخرى بتاثيره على
الاستقرار في الدول المجاوره مثل تشاد
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى ليبيا وجنوب
السودان ونصحت المجموعه الاحزاب السياسيه
وزعماء القبائل بالاستمرار في رفض
الانحياز لاي طرف ومنع الشعب من الانخراط
في القتال وحثت اللاعبين الاقليميين لا
سيما مصر وتشاد اثيوبيا وجنوب السودان
وارتيريا على تجنب دعم اي طرف من الاطراف
معنا من الخرطوم اللواء بدر الدين حسن عبد
الحكم الباحث في اكاديميه الامن العليا
لدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه سعاده
اللواء اهلا بك معنا في هذه النشره
والتغطيه المستمره لاحداث في السودان يعني
دعوات دوليه وتحذيرات من حرب اهليه برايك
هل يمكن ان تتصاعد الامور لتصبح حرب اهليه
مع المعطيات التي نراها في ارض المعركه
طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بالتاكيد يعني
هنالك حرب
كثير جدا
اغلاقها في الخرطوم يعني القوه الاساسيه
التي كانت في المرحله الاولى
التي كانت
تهاجم ببدايه المرحله الثانيه المرحله الى
جنوب الخرطوم وتم ضرب عدد كبير جدا من
المتحركات
لان عدد كبير من الجنود هم من من
تحول هذه الحرب الحرب الاهليه حتى الذين
دخلوا في ازقه وشوارع الجانبيه
اطراف المطار ولا يوجد حاضنه شعبيه لهم بل
كان
المواطنين يبلغون عن وجود هؤلاء
المنازل قناصه او عرض او سيارات رباعيه
الدفع في الاصدقاء الان الخطوه السطوه
للقوات المسلحه الجويه والقوات البريه
وهؤلاء يبغضون عناصر اساسيه لا تجعلهم
يستمر
سريعا المتمردان ان تاتي بالامداد من
الغرب حوالي في ثلاثه دفعات تم تدمير
ثلاثه اكثر من 280 سياره تم تدميرها مما
ابغضهم الامل
او وقود من الغرب الان اصبح محاوله ايضا
بعد الذخائر تاتي من الشرق وايضا دمرت
وثم تدميرها المشكله للاتصال ات هذه
القوات لا يوجد بين لا يوجد بين اتصالات
حديثه والان يستعملون الاتصالات العاديه
وهي طبعا سلاح
الدين يعني معروفا عند عشر الاخباريه لذلك
استعماله الاجهزه العاديه في التلفونات
ولا يوجد عنهم اتصالات حديثه او اتصالات
مشفره او لذلك هم الان
في مجموعات صغيره ثلاثه سيارات تنفع
سيارات في وسط وسط الخرطوم لكن بعد بدايه
المرحله الثانيه وتمدد القوات المسلحه
وشرق المطار تم الدفع الى خارج ولايه
الخرطوم عندما تحدث المراد
عليها
يبدو ان الاشتباكات تتصاعد في الخرطوم
وتعلو اصوات الاشتباكات لنستمع قليلا
طيب اعود اليك سعاده اللواء بدر الدين
يعني يبدو ان الاشتباكات مستمره وتتصاعد
العاصمه الخرطوم والوضع في يعني حقيقه
اكثر واكثر طيب اذا كنا نتحدث عن احتماليه
قيام حرب اهليه من عدمه في السودان ولكن
في هذه الاثناء ايضا هناك النداءات دوليه
ومحاولات عده من
لاجلاء مواطنين يعني على
عكس الاشتباك
ات ولا يعني ولا محاولات اجلاء خصوصا من
جانب امريكا ودول اخرى المانيا منذ يومين
حاولت اجراء مواطنيها وفاشلت الان تحاول
مره اخرى لدينا كوريا الجنوبيه اليابان
امريكا وعده دول اخرى يحاولون اجلاء
مواطنهم ما دلالات ذلك في هذه الايام
مواضع سكن اليابانيين وطبعا من
الدبلوماسيين المختلفين وكان هدفهم ان
يتحدث المتفق باذن الله
لذلك لجوا الى العمل الان
الدوله لا لا ترفض
اي اعلان
وحزيمه السريع هو واحد يعني
تم تحديد بعض المواقع في الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري للجنود ان يسلموا اسلحتهم ويدخلوا
لبعض المواقع
في الملعب التحرير الخرطوم تجاوبه استجابه
عدد كبير من الناس من الدعم السريع فالعدد
منهم كانوا يخدمون سيارات رباعيه
وياخذون الوجبات وياخذونه ملابس مدنيه لا
يوجد اي حرف اهليه الان
عند هجمات كثير من الذين يفاهموا من غوات
الدعم لعدد من المشدات
التي دخل انهيار ولا يوجد اطباء ولا يوجد
ادويه يلغون بالموقع
مشكله
تابعه للمتبردين
موقع هدفوا فيها الى الى وهذا هو السبب
الذي جعلك كثير من المنظمات تتحدث عن هذا
العمليه الموجوده الجثث في الطرق لكن
المسلحه داخل متواصله الان عندها مستشفى
ضخمه جدا رائع رائع غائده طبيه يبغى لها
الجرحى الان معروف طبعا
المهاجم في رحمه رحمه المداخل فالمرحله
الاولى الصمود التفضي كانت القوات المسلحه
اين تقع هذه القاعده الطبيه التي تتحدث
عنها
في مدينه وهي مؤمنه والبرمان بالمناسبه 95
ل98%
في الجيوب في غرب غرب ام درمان وجنوب
درمان وتم التعامل مع عدد منها
المشكله الاساسيه في الغرب المطار وجود
بعض القناص الاجانب الموجودين في اسطح
المنازل وتم الغوابه الخاصه تصدر
من عماره المبنى الى مبنى
ان كان المواطنين المعلومات
الموجودين على السطوح واشكالهم
وتعاملت معهم
الحجامه من مدينه دبي لانه هذا الخط الذي
يقع جنوب المطر
من الفرسان الهجانه والموافق خاصه لتنظيم
شرق المطار
جنوب ام درمان لذلك
المذيع عند المرافق عندكم
دفعت الى مدني
وكانت احدث
ت المدني لكنها تم القضاء عليها تماما مع
عهده هذه العربات سياره رباعيه الدفع
لاندكروزر
كان موجود فيها عدد من من المغربين من
المتبرج ثم القضاء عليهم وبعض العربات
تصنيع الحربي لكنهم دخلوا الى المتاجر وين
ولم وخرجوا بعدا داخل تصنيع الحربي
يعني ابين لكم الخارطه تماما الان وجود
التمر المتمردين في اقصى شمال الخرطوم
وهذا متى تحدث عنه اللواء الصحفي خالد
الفكي قبل قليل بان الصراع انتقل من وسط
الخرطوم الى اطرافها وحدودها هل انت تؤكد
ذلك ايضا
التي نستمع اليها من الخرطوم مباشره سعاده
اللواء اين هي في محيط المطار ام قصر
الرئاسيات الموجوده المقطوعه في وسط
الخرطوم وتحاول ان تخرج الى الطريق
الرئيسي
غرب الخرطوم كانت غادي من الغرب ثم توس
عدد من العربات التي تحمل الامداد من
الشرق من دول من دوله جاره الان هذه
الرواه رحمه المواطنين ورحمه
المواطن المسلحه تجد الدعمه من الحافظ
الشعبيه
تقدمون المشروبات والحلوى من الاطفال بكل
الطرق الخرطوم واتجه بعد الغرى واحتفلت
بالانتظارات حقيقه تم كسر حجه التمر
طيب ساعات اللواء ابقى معي
لنشير الى ان
فتيل ومع دخول الاشتباكات في السودان
السودانها الثاني اجرى رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الامريكيه مارك مالي اجرت اتصالا
هاتفيا مع قائد العام من القوات المسلحه
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان واوضح
المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
جوزيف هولز ان الطرفين ناقشا سلامه
المواطنين الامريكيين وتطورات الاوضاع وما
يحدث في السودان
هذا ورحب وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتن
بلنكن باعلان الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع التزامهما بوقف اطلاق النار لمده
ثلاثه ايام خلال عيد الفطر وقال بلانكين
في بيان نشرته الخارجيه الامريكيه انه
تحدث مع رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وتحدث مع
قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدانو
وحثهما على الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار
خلال هذه الفتره
نائب المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه بتيل اوضحها بدوره انه يجب ان
لا يتوقع المواطنون الامريكيون في السودان
اجل ان تنسقه الحكومه الامريكيه وقالبتيه
خلال افاده اعلاميه انه بالنظر الى اغلاق
مطار الخرطوم والوضع الامني غير المستقر
في البلاد يتعين على المواطنين هناك اتخاذ
الترتيبات الخاصه بهم للبقاء في امان
نظرا للوضع الامني غير المستقر في الخرطوم
وقرار اغلاق المطار انه غير امن حاليا
اجراء اخلاء من قبل الحكومه الامريكيه يجب
ان لا يتوقع الامريكيون المتواجدون في
السودان اخلاء من قبل الولايات المتحده في
هذا الوقت وانه من المتوقع ان يظل الوضع
هكذا في الوقت الحالي
على الجانب الاخر قل قائد قوه الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف باسم
حميدتي قال انه تلقى اتصالا هاتفيا من
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش مشيرا الى انهما ناقشا جميع
القضايا المتعلقه بالازمه الراهنه في ضوء
الهدنه الانسانيه واهميه فتح ممرات امنه
للمواطنين والمقيمين واهميه تسهيل حركتهم
من اجل الحصول على المساعدات الممكنه
واضاف حميتي انه مع غوتيريش اكد على ضروره
الالتزام بالوقوف الكامل لاطلاق النار
وتوفير الحمايه للعاملين في الحقل
الانساني والطبي لا سيما موظف الامم
المتحده والمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه
دعم مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل لوقف القتال في
السودان وحمايه المدنيين والرعايه الاجانب
وقال بوريل على تويتر انه تحدث مع وزير
خارجيه بريطانيا جيمس كليفري بشان الوضع
في السودان مشددا على ضروره تكثيف الجهود
وتعزيز التعاون بين البلدين من اجل التوصل
لاتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار في السودان
كما بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان ونظيره البريطاني جيمس
كليفرلي بحثا تطورات في السودان وذلك خلال
اتصال هاتفي واكد وزير خارجيه السعوديه
وبريطانيا على اهميه وقف التصعيد في
السودان وانهاء اعمال العنف كما شددا على
ضروره توفير الحمايه للمدنيين في السودان
من لندن ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي خالد
الاعسر اهلا بك معنا سيد خالد اذن وسطات
دوليه ومحاولات امميه ودوليه لانهاء
الصراع او حتى وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
ولكن لا تنجح وايضا الهدنه كذلك لا تنجح
ما السبب برايك
تحيه لمستمعيكم الكرام ومره اخرى كل عام
وانتم بخير نترحم على ارواح الشهداء في
السودان انا في
تقدير الشخصي ان السبب السبب الاساسي الى
عدم نجاح الهدنه يكمن في ان التقدم الكبير
الذي والاختراق الكبير الذي حققه الجيش
السوداني في هذه المعركه
عندما دمر مراكز القياده والسيطره وتدعم
السريع كانت هناك اثار ونتائج سلبيه وهذا
بديه وبطبيعي ان لم تكون هناك حاله انقطاع
وعدم تواصل مع القياده بين القوات التي
كانت انتشرت في عدد من المواقع ليس فقط في
الخرطوم وانما على امتداد ارض السودان في
الساعات الاولى من هذا الهجوم
وبالتالي يصبح هؤلاء جميعا وقد افتقدوا
بدءا عنصر الاتصال مع قيادتهم العسكريه
التي تتمثل في محمد حمدان دوبلو وشقيقه
وبعض عيادات الدعم السريع وهذا مفهوم في
السياق العسكري هذا بالاضافه الى تسليم
عدد من قيادات الوحدات العسكريه التابعه
للتوات الدعم السريع قبيل هذه العمليه وفق
ما جاء من قرارات استجابت لها هذه
القيادات بالانسلاخ من الدعم السريع بعد
ان اهنها الفريق البرهان انتداب عدد من
المنتسبين لهذه القوات وتعلمين ان هذه
القوات هي جزء لا ينفصل من الدوله
السودانيه حتى في تركيبه المهنيه هي قوات
مسانده خرجت من صلبه الجيش وبالتالي
عوده هؤلاء ايضا تسببت في عدل لبعض
القيادات الميدانيه
بالاضافه الى الانتشار الكثيف والضغط الذي
مارسته ربما الاعلى اله الجيش السوداني في
سلاح الطيران وفرغت هؤلاء الجنود وانتصروا
في الاحياء وفي عدد من المناطق في ساعات
سابقه وبالتالي هذا يعني يضرر فكره عدم
تواصلهم مع غيادتهم وحتى ابتعادهم عن
وسائل الاعلام
سيد خالد ولكن ماذا عن الوسطات الدوليه
والتدخلات الدوليه لمحاوله التهدئه ووقف
اطلاق النار ايضا لا تنجح كذلك
كيف يعني انا اتعجب ان الاتصالات ربما
مقطوعه بصفه كامله على القيادات وهي حاله
تمثل نفس
الحاله تندرج على الفعل السياسي الذي يرى
لتوفيق الاوضاع والعوده الى طاوله تفاوض
ونغاز حول قضيه ايقاف
الاتصالات هاتفيه
سمو الامير وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان واتصالات اخرى من للجانبين كذلك
لمحاوله التهدئه هناك محاولات للتواصل الى
تهدئه وبالفعل يستطيعون التوصل لهم التحدث
الى قياده الطرفان
في تقدير الشخصي طالما ان الحرب على الارض
رجح في كفه الجيش السوداني على قيادات
الدعم السريعه التي تتواصل مع بعض
الرموز وبعض الشخصيات الدوليه ان تعلن
اكثر من هدنه ليس فقط هدنه ان تعلن رغبه
في ايقاف هذه الحرب نهائيا وتسليم اسلحه
لان هذا يعني امر تجاوز الزمن
الابيات كبيره تمد على الصعيد
السودان وان هناك محازير ومخاوف على الامن
والاستغرام في السودان بحكم ان
هناك ارتباطات لبعض الجهات ما تعلمين ان
كثير من التسريبات التي تمت ان بعض
المنتسبين لهذه القوات تركوا السودان
وغادروا كما هو التصريح الشهير الذي جعل
لسان الجنرال وزير الدفاع التشادي الجنرال
داوود يا ابراهيم الذي تحدث عن وصول اكثر
من 320 جندي وسلم
ولكل المعدات العسكريه التي كانت بحوزتهم
يعني هذا السؤال بديه لماذا خرج هؤلاء الى
التشاد اذا كانوا هم فعلا يتبعون لغوات
الدعم الشريعه السودانيه هذا السؤال بديهي
مهم جدا يعني يفترض ان تجيب عليه قياده
الدعم السريع يعني هناك اشياء تتطلب
التمسك بالمواقف الوطنيه انا اؤكد لك يا
سيدتي ان الشعب السوداني يقف على اقل برجل
واحد في هذه القضيه القضيه منذ ان بدات
يعني هي كانت لم تكن موفقه من قياده الدعم
السريع انها دفعت بالسوداني هذا المنحى لا
يزال هناك صوت عقلي يطالب بالدعوه الى
تحكيم صوت العقل والعوده الى فكره الغاء
السلاح اول الاندماج داخل
الصدر بخصوص دمج
القوات حرس الحدود وهذه قضيه اساسيه تضمن
لكل منتسبي هذه القوات ان يكونوا
بكل تاكيد سيد خالد ولكن لنتحدث قليلا عن
هذه الصور المباشره امامنا حيث نشاهد
طيران يحلق في سماء الخرطوم لنستمع قليلا
واعود اليك
اذا الاشتباكات وصوت طلق النار المتبادل
بين الدعم السريع والجيش ما زال مستمر وفي
تصاعد وراينا قبل قليل طائره تحلق في سماء
الخرطوم كذلك سيد خالد اعود اليك يعني
نتحدث عن الوضع الداخلي في السودان وذكرت
بان الشعب السوداني على اقلب الرجل واحد
بكل تاكيد ولكن لنتحدث عن سيناريوهات تمدد
هذه الازمه الى خارج السودان ربما يعني
هناك كانت تحضيرات دوليه
لمناطق المحيطه كذلك من ان تتمدد هذه
الازمه الى الخارج ما مدى احتماليه حدوث
ذلك برايك
في كثير من الاشياء ربما تحتاج الى تصحيح
وليس فقط قضيه تشاد ودول الجوار وتاتي الى
ذلك لاحقا لكن فكره انها ربما تقود الى
حرب اهليه او هي الان حرضها لهذا غير صحيح
التعريف العلمي للهرب الاهليه هي نزاع علي
بين الدوله والاطراف او اطراف او طرف خارج
منظومه الدوله الحكومه علي وبالتالي الذي
يحدث في السودان الان هو يختلف تماما من
فكره الحرب الاهليه هي ليست الحرب الاهليه
هي حرب بين قوه رسميه تمردت عنها قوه
عسكريه وهذا في العلوم السياسيه والعسكريه
معروف كيفيه التعامل معه وهذا ابتداء
ثانيا كل القبائل السودانيه بتعددها
الحسائيه الممزوج بالروح السودانيه
الجميله هذه كلهم
مسلحه السودانيه
يحتفلون امس بالعيد في مواقع المسلحه
خرجوا في مواكب صرح باسم القوات المسلحه
كل الشعب السوداني
لصالح الشعب مثلا في القوات التي تمثل هذه
ابتداء ثانيا في دول الجوار دول
الجوار من يتضرر من اندلاع اي نوع من
الصراعات في السودان وبالتالي كل دول الج
الا دوله واحده ربما قد لا يهمه ابر
السودان بالحجم الكبير ولكنها صرحت عبر
المسؤولين لا نريد ان
نوى في هذه المرحله
جاده فعلا ان لا تتدخل في الشان السوداني
يجب ان لا تضع عن الجيش السوداني من ظهره
لانها وكما يعني يعلم الجميع انها اقامت
محاوله عسكريه في صبيحه اليوم التي تعرض
فيه الدعم السريع وهذا يصنف فعل غير
العميد في تصنيف الشعب السوداني ايضا في
هذه المرحله
بجوار نستطيع ان اجزم لك وقد التقيت عدد
من الغاده في هذه الدول
لانها ستؤثر تاثيره مباشره على الامن
والاستقرار في الاقليم والمنطقه
والعالم ليس من مصلحه حرب في هذه المنطقه
لاسيما من البحر الاحمر وتعلمين ان الدول
العربيه بهذا الشان مصر العربيه دوله ايضا
تتاثر كثيرا بهذا الفعل
حريصه انها تصرح تصريحات تمشي عن نفسها
تهمه ماء حتى لا تستغل اليها العدوى تشاد
اغلقت الحدود افريقيا الوسطى لديها موقف
ثابت العلاقات الدوليه الممتده بين هذه
الدول في منطقه وسط وغرب افريقيا هي
علاقات مع يعني متينه وتاريخيه مع الدوله
فرنسا فرنسا اخر همها ان تندلع حروف في
هذه المنطقه وبالتالي هي فكره تمدد الصراع
السوداني كل العالم كل المزاج الدولي
والاقليمي ما عدا بعض الدول الصغيره التي
تريد ان تفعل بعض الصراعات
خالد تحدثت عن بالفعل اشتباكات ومحاولات
لدخول الحدود السودانيه من قبل اثيوبيا
وقوات اثيوبيه احمد ابي احمد خرج ونفى ذلك
بطبيعه الحال ولكن هل اثيوبيا تحاول
استغلال الصراع في السودان
لازمه الحدود بينها وبين السودان
وما الذي جاء بمحمد علي باشا الى السودان
وما الذي جاء
بالاستعمار البريطاني بكتشر وغردون وكل
هذه المعارك والسجلات الناصعه في تاريخ
الشعب السوداني هي كلها مرده للمطامع
الدوليه منذ اكثر من قرنين او السودان
دوله غنيه يسيل لها اللعاب كل العالم وليس
دول الجوار السودان لديه موارد وقدران في
خلال هذه الاربع سنوات التي انقضت الموارد
التي تهربت من السودان بفعل السيول
الامنيه والهشاشه والمواكب التي كانت
تختلف الخرطوم لبعض الناس الذين كانوا في
في نوم العميق ولا يعلمون ان المخطط اكبر
من حجم القدراتهم الذهنيه وتفكير ظللنا
نطرق الاجراس وننبه ونحذر ونتحدث ونكتب
حتى لا يفز السنتنا نحذر من ان السودان
يتجه نحو صراعات لو لم نتدارك الامر لاننا
نعلم ونعيش في الغرب ودرسنا في الغرب
ونعلم العقليه الغربيه ونعلم كيفيه
السيطره على موارد الامم ونعلم
الاستراتيجيات العسكريه كل درسناه دراسه
السودان دوله فيها خير كبير العالم يطمع
في في في الحصول على موارد السودان وهذه
قضيه يجب ان ينتمي لها الشعب السوداني
وانا متاكد تمام التاكيد ان الشعب
السوداني الصلي ولا تزيد المعارك الصغيره
هذه
الاكبر من الصراعات داخل
السودان بالتاكيد والاصحاب المطامع
التاريخيه في موارد الشعب السوداني ولهذا
انا اتحدث واستغرق كثيرا الدعم السريع
فيها من يرفع السلاح ويوجه لي الاله التي
لمؤسسه التي خرج من رحمها بحجه انه
حمايه الشعب السوداني
الشعب السوداني لا يمكن ان تنقل اليه
الدواء الديمراطيه عبر تنتقل اليه
الديمقراطيه عبر فوهات البنادق الشعب
السوداني هو الذي علم الشعوب اعني
علمه الشعوب كيفيه العمل
الشموليه وترسيخ القيامه الديمقراطيه هو
الذي اقام ثوره اكتوبر 64 وقتها كان الناس
يظنون في نوم عميق في افريقيا والعالم
العربي لا يعرفون معنى كلمه ديمقراطيه حتى
وفي 1985
وجميعهم خرجوا في تلك الاونه يحملون
اغصانا الاديم والنجار الخضراء
ولم يحملوا البندقيه واحده كانوا يحملون
الشعارات السلميه كيف تريد ان
تراقب وكيف لك لا تقرا التاريخ السوداني
السوداني انهزموا ومحمد علي باشا
في مروي في كرري عفوا في شيكان
كل من يتدخل من الخارج
هذا ان لديها عناصر خارجيه وانا امرك موجه
رساله للذين يتحدثون والقوات هم لا يقيمون
في السودان ولا يعلمون مراره من وضع
الحاليه ويتحدثون باسم الدعم السريع من
خارج السودان في الفنادق وفي وفي الشقق
التي يختاروها من اموال الشعب السوداني
خلال هذه الاربعه اعوام يجب ان يقشوا عن
التضعيف الصراع في السودان ويجب ان يرفع
يدين ويجب ان يعودوا الى كلمه سواء ويحتكم
الى صوت العقل ويدعو قياداتهم وعساكين
كل تاكيد سيد خالد نتمنى الامن والامان
والكلمه الموحده للسودانيين بكل تاكيد
شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن الكاتب الصحفي خالد
فتيل المواجهه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
وصل الى ابواب السجون حيث اتهم الجيش
السوداني قوات الدعم السريع بالهجوم على
سجن الهدى في ام درمان واطلاق سراح عدد
كبير من النزلاء في المقابل نفذ قوات
الدعم السريع ما وصفتها بمزاعم متداوله
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عن اقتحام
عناصرها للسجن وقالت انها مدبحت سابقا في
بيان من عمليات توزيع قواتها على عناصر
وقفتهم بالفلول لتنفيذ اعمال اجراميه
والصاق التهمه بالدعم السريع
قال الدكتور علاء الدين عوض عضو لجنه
الاستشاريين الطبيه في السودان للعربيه
قال ان الاحصائيات تشير حتى اللحظه الى
مقتل اكثر من 300 شخص واصابه نحو 1700
اخرين محذرا من وجود عدد كبير من الجثث
والقتله في الاحياء المدنيه
لغايه الان هو تقريبا الاحصائيات مشعل 300
قتيل
وتقريبا حوالي اثنين وسبعميه جريح لا زالت
في الاحياء ولا زالت زي ما قلت في الشوارع
في كميه من القتله في كميه من الفيديوهات
اللي تخرج في السوشيال ميديا بتوري
الشوارع الحاصل بالذات باكد على مشكله
الشوارع دي لانها في بدات التحلل انتفقت
وبدا بالتحلل وحقيقه دي حتكون كارثه صحيه
هذا وافادت وسائل الاعلام بريطانيه بان
بريطانيا وضعت قوات وطائرات تابعه لها في
وضع الاستعداد ولم يتم الافصاح عن المكان
الذي تتواجد فيه القوات البريطانيه سوى
انها تتمركز في قاعده بالخارج حيث سيتم
اللجوء لهذه القوات والطائرات في حال
الحاجه اليها لاجلاء موظفي السفاره
والرعايه البريطانيين من السودان
السودان لم يتحول فقط الى حلبه صراع
للاطراف المتناحره بل بات ايضا سجنا كبيرا
لاخرين باحثين عن النجات فبلموازات مع
المساعي لتطبيق وقف اطلاق النار تبذل
الكثير من الدول الكبرى جهودا جباره من
اجل ايجاد حل لاجلاء رعاياها لكن كيف
السبيل الى ذلك عمليه الاجلاء تصطدم
بالعديد من العراقيل اهمها توقف العمل في
الكثير من المطارات الحيويه في البلاد من
بينها مطار الخرطوم وبالتالي فان عمليه
الاجلاء الجوي تبقى معقده للغايه حيث تمر
عبر الاستعانه بمطار اخر والاسم المقترح
مبدئيا هو مطار بورسودان لكن عدم توقف
الاشتباكات يجعل من مغادره الخرطوم عمليه
محفوفه بالمخاطر
الاجلاء البري ايضا يبقى صعبا للغايه في
ظل بعد المسافات بين العاصمه وحدود الدول
المجاوره فضلا على ان الطرقات ليست امنه
بشكل كبير
اجلاء الوفود العالقه في السودان اخذ بعدا
دوليا كبيرا حيث تسابق دول عديده الزمن
لانقاذ رعاياها من جحيم المعارك الاتحاد
الاوروبي بدا فعليا وضع خطط لعمليات اجلاء
المحتمله لرعاياه لكنه اقر ان الظروف
الامنيه غير متوفره للمضي في عمليه كهذه
المشكله ذاتها اعربت عنها الكثير من الدول
كاسبانيا وسويسرا والسويد اما الولايات
المتحده فبادرت الى التحرك لانقاذ رعاياها
من خلال نشر قوات لها في جيبوتي تاهبا لاي
مهمه انقاذ محتمله مهمه تزداد تعقيدا كل
ما ازدادت حده المعارك وسام الذهبي
العربيه
اعود الى الخرطوم وظيفي من هناك اللواء
بدر الدين حسن عبد الحكم الباحث في
اكاديميه الامن العليا للدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه اذا سعاده اللواء ارحب بك
مجددا محاولات لاجلاء المواطنين اود ان
افهم منك تحديدا عمليه الاجلاء كيف تتم
تحديدا وماذا تحتاج هل تحتاج لقوات دعم هل
تحتاج لقدرات معينه لاخلاء واجلاء مواطنين
المواطنين الدبلوماسيين للدول الخارجيه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحقيقه كانت
هنالك بعض الحجمات على قوات الدعم الشريعه
المتمرده الى على بعض الدبلوماسيه وبجزء
منه من
هذه الهجمات التي قام بها الدعم الشريعي
وهي عمل مقصود بنفسه بهذا اشاره المجتمع
الدولي ضد ضد
الجيش السوداني لكن الان معلوم ان ان
القوات المسلحه تحركت في كل
المساحات الجنوبيه للخرطوم
الرسمي الى الى الى مدى قطع
الطريق
لمن المطارات الاثنين مطارات دوليه وممكن
يتم الاخلاق بها انما هي عامل زمن فقط
عامل زمن لان القوات المسلحه الان بلغت
حتى وهو النت اندفعت نحو مدينه مدني تم
تدميرها ولذلك
السيارات وضعيه الدفع دخلت وسط الجزيره
وتم التعامل معها حتى المواطنين يتعاملون
واغلب هذه العربات التي تنفرد وته اغلب
جنودها يريدون ان يسلموا خوفا من الخوف
اذا كان المجموعه يخافوا من الاعدامات
التي تلفظ ضدهم لكن اذا فرد لسياره
سيارتينهم يسلمون المواطنين
يعني اليوم او غبي اذا تم فتح قريب
مدينه الخرطوم بعض انطلاقه العمليه
الثانيه الجزء
الثاني من عمليات
لحد اللقاء اليوم
الخرطوم امنه ام درمان فيها موجود فيها
اكثر من ثلاثه مليون شخص معان الاسواق
تعمل حتى ضاحيه اقصى جنوب الخرطوم وهي
خاليه من التمرد والاجواء تعمل يعني جزء
كبير الحرف كلها موجوده
السريع المسلحه على هذه الواتس اندفع الى
المطار الى جنوب الخرطوم حول حول
وسط العاصمه وضحت الصوره شكرا لك من
الخرطوم اللواء بدر الدين حسن عبد الحكم
الباحث في اكاديميه الامن العليا للدراسات
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات